i want to take a moment to once again uh
thank the fans
who sent me their pictures uh several
months ago
so we could fill the theater with their
cardboard
cutouts i mean just hundreds and
hundreds of
fans sent in these photographs we turn
them into these cutouts
now they've got christmas hats and it's
just been absolutely
lovely i mean look at them all dressed
up for the holidays and it really does
as silly as it sounds
it really does make it feel like there's
a lot of love in the room yeah it does
it does each one of these represents
somebody that cared enough to
do this yeah which is lovely so here's
what i thought
i decided to double down on the holiday
spirit here at the largo theater
i asked the props department they're
very good they're very skilled
to turn a few of our fans into a conan
audience advent calendar you've heard of
advent calendars haven't you andy
yeah sure the calendars with the little
doors you open up in the days leading up
to christmas i mean and there's supposed
to be like a treat behind the door
yeah yeah sometimes there's a real nice
treat in there it's a little surprise
every day my kids do it they love it
so uh please help me out andy because
this is really unique this has never
been attempted before
in the history of uh late night
television let's check out
the conan audience advent calendar
okay andy tell us who's our first
audience member uh well this is
uh kevin tennant from lansing michigan
let's see what he's got
all right oh
it's a chocolate santa oh
isn't that nice that's great well thank
you kevin
yeah got chocolate sand in his head yeah
tell me uh who's next
uh we've got naomi sherman of monsi new
york here let's see what she's got
oh it's a dreidel it says i'm jewish
yeah that works and i straddle as she is
jewish happy hanukkah naomi yeah thanks
naomi
okay this is fun i think it's really
working out well who's next
uh the next one is jane lee of houston
texas
i bet she's full of treats
[Music]
well that's a little disappointing okay
there's time for one more randy
all right well our final audience advent
calendar is claire drummond
she's a proud grandmother from pensacola
florida let's see what you got
claire oh look at that
whole package of tube socks here we go
let's see it's probably
oh look it must be a subscription to
national
geographic that's so nice and then oh
world's best grandson thanks claire
there's got to be some more in here
let's see
[Music]
look it's a hat
red for christmas yeah
maybe uh maybe put that back in
there you go claire yeah well anyway
that concludes the first
and very last conan audience advent
[Music]
calendar